des combats toujours plus meurtrier
cela fait maintenant près de deux
semaines que les forces armées des rêves
à la nef de bapaume où s'affrontent sur
le terrain
d'intenses bombardements dans le
haut-karabagh qui ne s'interrompent pas
les nombreux appels internationaux au
cessez-le-feu n'y font rien après une
réunion à ce sujet hier à genève entre
la délégation azerbaïdjanaise et les
représentants du groupe de minsk
coprésidé par paris moscou et washington
les discussions doivent se poursuivre ce
vendredi le kremlin invite les chefs des
diplomaties arméniennes et
azerbaïdjanaises dans la capitale russe
pour négocier le 9 octobre les ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'azerbaïdjan
et de l'arménie sont invités à moscou
pour mener des consultations le
président de la russie appelle à l'arrêt
des combats au nagorny karabach pour des
raisons humanitaires
erevan et bakou ne semble pas fermé à un
cessez le feu mais les points de blocage
sont encore tenaces notamment jeté au
jet card à tout prix sauf route quand
des radicaux et des terroristes
internationaux se trouve là la région
devient une menace pour la sécurité du
monde entier et bien sur l'implication
de la turquie a une influence
il est évident que comme tout conflit
si nous souhaitons vraiment le résoudre
des compromis sont nécessaires nous
sommes attachés à une résolution
pacifique et négocié du conflit
le seul fait que l'azerbaïdjan et
participer aux négociations indique que
l'azerbaïdjan est attachée à une
solution pacifique
mais ce que nous constatons ces derniers
temps ce que l'arménie continue ses
provocations
cela viole le cessez-le-feu même si nous
respectons de nouveau le cessez le feu
qui pourrait garantir que ces
provocations ne se poursuivront pas
c'est pourquoi nous disons que l'arménie
doit commencer immédiatement retirer ses
forces des territoires azerbaïdjanais
occupés
l'urgence est de mise dans la région
séparatiste majoritairement peuplée
maignien les derniers bilans officiels
probablement en deçà de la réalité font
état de 300 à 400 morts dont plusieurs
dizaines de civils